pergunta problemas de absorção de
nutrientes tem como resolver
naturalmente sem tomar medicação bem
esses problemas de absorção podem ser
resolvidos de várias formas tanto com
medicamentos tanto com abordagens
naturais integrativas primeiramente é
importante entender que a absorção de
nutrientes pode ser afetado por várias
situações pode ser problemas no trato
digestório como deficiências enzimáticas
e disbiose ou até mesmo por certas
doenças neurológicas como a doença de
paron que pode causar constipação e
dificuldade de engolir então para
resolver esse problema de forma natural
eu vou dar aqui algumas sugestões dieta
balanceada alimentação consciente ou
seja uma dieta rica em frutas legumes
grãos integrais proteínas de alta
qualidade gorduras de alta qualidade
isso pode ajudar a garantir a ingestão
adequada de nutrientes Além disso comer
devagar mastigar muito bem os seus
alimentos isso Vai facilitar muito a
digestão que lá começa na boca as
pessoas não se lembram disso e a
suplementação mática pode ajudar
bastante porque muitas vezes a abação de
nutrientes ela foi afetada por
deficiências enzimáticas então seuse
suplementos nessa linha podem ser úteis
para quebrar melhor os alimentos e
suplementos ajudam a quebrar os
alimentos e nutrientes mais facilmente
absorvíveis e pros disbiótico pode ser
muito útil o uso de probióticos Man ter
uma flora intestinal saudável Muito
importante você sabe disso então esses
probióticos nós encontramos em alimentos
fermentados como iogurte como quefir
como nator eles podem ajudar a
equilibrar a flora intestinal e beber
bastante água tem uma hidratação
adequada essencial paraa digestão e
absorção de nutrientes e a desidratação
pode piorar Então os sintomas os
problemas de absorção E como sempre a
redução de estresse é muito importante
porque o estresse crônico pode afetar a
digestão e absorção de nutrientes Então
faça meditação yoga terapia de
relaxamento que vão ajudar a reduzir o
estress como sempre evitar os alimentos
processados refinados e izados vai
ajudar porque eles têm muito aditivo
substâncias que atrapalham a barreira
intestinal e vão interferir na absorção
de nutrientes então opte por alimentos
naturais integrais e orgânicos Se for
possível e consulte um profissional um
nutricionista médico para acompanhar o
seu caso